es hora de repasar las noticias de la
actualidad económica internacional y nos
acompaña para ello en el estudio Daniela
hablandon Buenos días Hola Buenos días
Rosa primera vez acá a las dos
exactamente Daniela hoy se lleva a cabo
la que podría ser la última reunión de
creatures Sí señora pues de la reunión
anual del banco de 167 años en proceso
de fusión con su principal rival y vs
comenzó con una disculpa pública del
presidente ejecutivo entre los furiosos
accionistas escuchemos
queríamos poner toda nuestra energía y
capacidad para cambiar el banco me duele
que no haya llegado el momento y que
estas fatales semanas de marzo
arruinaron nuestros planes Lo siento
mucho
al final no había más que las siguientes
opciones trato o quiebra la única
alternativa era reestructurar legalmente
el banco de lo contrario en el peor de
los casos habría llevado a la Pérdida
total de valor para los accionistas un
enorme daño a los clientes terribles
consecuencias para la economía y los
mercados financieros globales
Rosa y es que después de años de
escándalos y pérdidas estuvo al borde
del colapso antes de que yo hubiese
saliera al rescate ahora el proceso
enfrenta varios desafíos legales por un
lado la fusión diseñada y financiada por
las autoridades suizas se pasó por alto
a los accionistas precisamente a los que
están reunidos hoy y su precio de un
poco más de 3 mil millones de dólares
fue un 60% menos de lo que costaba un
bolso en ese momento además el casi
colapso del banco borró de un plumazo 17
mil millones de dólares de los llamados
bonos at1 cuyos tenedores alegan que
tenían prioridad de pago estos
inversionistas ya contrataron a un
temido bufete de abogados para exigir
una compensación finalmente la oficina
del fiscal general dijo haber abierto
una investigación sobre la adquisición
allí en Suiza Daniela y recordamos esos
días precisamente no de pánico en el
sistema sistema bancario pero cambiamos
de información porque a tesla lo
condenaron por tolerar el racismo Pues
un Jurado federal en San Francisco le
ordenó a la empresa del multimillonario
elon musk pagar unos 3,2 millones de
dólares a un ex empleado negro
Owen Díaz fue ascensorista de la fábrica
de vehículos eléctricos en California y
señaló a la gerencia de no actuar cuando
se quejó repetidamente de que sus
compañeros usaban insultos racistas y
dibujaban caricaturas suyas en las
paredes y en áreas de trabajo el Jurado
le otorgó 17 Ah no 175 mil dólares por
daños como angustia emocional y también
tres millones de dólares en daños
punitivos diseñados para castigar estas
conductas ilegales y para disuadirlas en
un futuro dijo en un tuitter que El
veredicto había sido cero habría sido
cero si el juez hubiera permitido
presentar nuevas pruebas pero que no lo
hizo dice y lo mosca y hablando de elon
más No pero otra compañías que están en
esta carrera espacial privada Se declaró
en quiebra Pues estamos hablando de
Virgin orbet del Magnate Richard branson
quien considera que su única opción es
la venta de activos después de anunciar
el despido de aproximadamente el 85% de
sus 750 empleados la semana pasada esta
firma ha tratado de lanzar cohetes desde
un avión Boeing 747 modificado para
poner satélites en órbita pero su sexta
misión que fue en enero del año pasado
de su cohete Launcher One fue lanzado
desde Gran Bretaña pues no logró
alcanzar la órbita y terminó sumergido
en el océano además enfrenta una gran
competencia de otros líderes de la
industria como spacex de elon musk
precisamente y pues hay que decir
también que hoy Virgin orved vale en
bolsa Apenas 65 millones de dólares hace
dos años costaba tres mil millones de
dólares y Daniela continuamos con vuelos
pero en este caso de aviones comerciales
Y es que Venezuela retoma
acorazado pues la frontera entre
Venezuela y las islas de Países Bajos en
el mar Caribe mantiene restricciones
desde febrero de 2019 luego de que el
opositor Juan guaidó intentará ingresar
al territorio venezolano una ayuda
humanitaria que se acopiaba Precisamente
en Brasil en Colombia y en las islas de
Curazao bonaire y aruba la reapertura
fue anunciada por el ministro de
transporte Ramón Velázquez quien resaltó
las negociaciones que se llevan a cabo
desde diciembre de 2022 para superar
todas estas tensiones políticas y que
también contemplan por ejemplo la
reapertura marítima entre Venezuela y
aruba Esto será a partir de mayo próximo
y cerramos Daniela con la cifra del día
que nos trae lo adelantábamos ya en
informativos 12,7 millones de libras
esterlinas Esa fue la multa que impuso
el regulador británico a tiktok por el
mal uso de datos de los niños
concretamente dice que la red social
permitió que hasta 1,4 millones de
menores de 13 años en su plataforma en
2020 a pesar de que establece esta edad
Como la mínima para crear una cuenta y
concluye que es posible que estos datos
hayan sido utilizados para rastrear a
estos niños Y perfilarlos lo que podría
presentarles contenido dañino o también
inapropiado estos menores Daniela pues
muchísimas gracias por este repaso a la
actualidad económica internacional nos
vemos mañana mañana nos vemos aquí y
ustedes se sigan con más información en
34.com enseguida
[Música]